hey you guys natalie here and welcome
back today it's a good life today i'm
going to show you
how to set up a worm farm or a worm bin
however you want to say it however big
your worm farm is
i'm going to show you how to set it up
today if we haven't met yet my name is
natalie i'm a backyard farmer here in
san diego california
urban homesteader urban farmer whatever
you want to call it we grow food in the
backyard and are learning how to do so
each and every day each and every season
as we steward our big regenerative farm
dreams hoping that one day very soon
we'll be on the farm but for now we make
the most of it in our backyard
growing food and raised beds that i
built myself you can catch the video
here
and we make all of our own nutrients on
site using worms this is our worm farm
and we make we make all of our nutrients
on site for amending our beds
for the most part using this worm farm
setup and today i'm going to show you
how you can set up
your own worm farm or worm bin so like i
said
this is our worm farm and i just
finished setting it up and today i want
to
invite you guys into the process and
show you guys how i set up our worm bins
from scratch now whether you've got a
smaller worm farm or a worm bin or
you've got a big old worm
farm like this one the same principles
will apply to you
you really just need a few things to get
started
[Music]
so let's talk supplies to set up your
worm bin you will need
cardboard browns bedding grit worms
greens and amendments if you feel so
inclined you'll also need a bin and some
water that is free of chemicals and
chlorine and i'll show you later on in
the video which amendments i prefer to
use
for our worm farm that help boost
production and minerals and all of that
good stuff
if you're a worm nerd or you're a
wannabe worm nerd go ahead and hit the
like button
down below and while you're there might
as well hit the subscribe and the bell
as well just saying
just saying i've gone through the
trouble of making you a little checklist
here
in my ebook so if you are wanting to get
started with worm farming
this ebook might be your best friend
with getting started
it covers everything from supplies with
checklists and
shopping lists so you can shop directly
online and just get everything straight
shipped to you set up harvest
maintenance
and ways to use your castings tips as
well as
questions and answers in the back of the
books i hope this is a resource that
proves really valuable to you
and it's what we'll be working out of
for today as we set up our bins
[Music]
to set up the bins first we add a layer
of cardboard and the cardboard is really
there to prevent the worms from
sneaking through and sneaking out of the
bins when you add worms to bins
they have a tendency to want to escape
it's sometimes a little hard for them
to acclimate to their new home and so
you want to
fortify your bins as much as possible to
prevent them from escaping
and we found that cardboard works best
but you could also use several layers of
newspaper or packing paper as well
next up we need to add some browns to
the worm bin and to do that you can add
anything from
shredded up cardboard shredded up
newspaper shut it up packing paper
shut it up envelopes although you'll
want to remove any glue
or plastic particles or anything like
that i prefer to use
leaves that i found in my backyard
they're free
they're readily available this time of
year in fall and
i find that anything that is more
natural tends to do a little bit better
so i lean towards using leaves as a
brown material whenever possible
next up to our worm bin we are going to
add some compost
now the compost has organic material
which is really
important for any kind of composting
setup a lot of people think oh well
you know worms will make anything better
but in reality
worms exist in nature where the soil
is already good because they have this
symbiotic relationship with the
nematodes and everything else that's
going on
inside the soil structure itself so
we can't just say i'm just going to add
worms to the situation and it's going to
be better
that's not really how it works and so
that's why it's important to add compost
because you're going to be adding a lot
of organic material that way and it's
going to help boost
the microbiome of these worm bins so
we're going to add our layer of compost
i like to think of it as making a little
bed for the worms right so this is their
bedding this is where they're starting
off their life
in the worm bin eventually everything
will basically turn into
castings but this is this is their start
and we want to be as hospitable
and loving and kind to these little
worms as we can so we're going to make
them a nice comfy bed
made of some soft organic material
compost
and soil so now all that's left to do is
add the worms to their bed
and then i like to include their grit
here with them and i'm adding grit in
the form
of coffee grinds eggshells and
vermiculite
grit is great for their digestion which
they need when they're first starting
off in the bin
they actually have gizzards and several
stomachs so they need a lot of grit to
help them process that is part of
the necessary components for digestion
in worms so it's important to include
grit which is why i include it here in
bed with them
as a nice little gritty snack while
they're
sleeping in their beds getting
acclimated in their new home
and i'm adding just a handful to each
bin these are new worms
all of our old worms have already been
added to our garden beds so i went ahead
and purchased some new ones from our
local feed store
i'm just adding a handful because under
the right conditions
these worms will multiply pretty quickly
and that's what we're hoping for a nice
healthy worm bin with
lots of new worm babies very soon pro
tip you can get coffee grounds from your
local coffee shop
i got mine from our local starbucks
starbucks has a program that they've had
around now for years where they give out
grounds to local gardeners but if you
establish a relationship with another
local business who
needs to get rid of their coffee grounds
it's a win-win for the coffee shop and
for you
good for them reducing their carbon
footprint good for you benefiting your
garden
then like i said i want you to think of
it as a bed we're gonna cover those
worms up with some soil make sure
they're nice
and comfortable not too hot not too cold
nice and comfortable in their new
environment and i'm just adding a little
bit of compost and soil
to cover them up and protect them from
the sunlight because
worms don't like sun they're
photosensitive so when you
pull out some a handful of worms and you
see them wriggling in your hands
they prefer not to be exposed to direct
sunlight so we want to make sure that
they are nice and covered up and
comfortable in their new home
and i like to do so by adding a little
bit more compost and soil
so next up it's time to add some food
scraps
[Music]
on behalf of worms and worm farmers
everywhere i'd like to welcome you to
the first ever episode of cooking for
your worms
in today's episode we'll show you how to
make a worm charcuterie board
today's stars of the show include what
wet bad in my fridge
we've got pears apple avocado a worm's
favorite food bananas a worm's second
favorite food
apple cores broccoli and eggshell
[Music]
because nothing says i love you worms
like slightly rotten fruits and veggies
and the smell of broccoli fart
now here are some things that you should
know about red wigglers and food scraps
in a worm bin
first off red wigglers are surface
dwellers that means that they're going
to want to hang out towards the top of
the worm bin
unlike things like earthworms or
european night crawlers which are all
other kinds of worms that you can find
in the garden or use for composting
but for my purposes i prefer to use red
wigglers and it's what i have linked
down below it's what i recommend for
getting started
what i love to experiment with european
night crawlers one day yeah
maybe but for now red wigglers have
worked really well for me keeping that
in mind
that their nature is to stay towards the
surface of the
worm bins it's important that we leave
their food there for them so
that's where they want to hang out and
eat contrary to popular belief
another thing you should know is that
worms don't eat just
food scraps i definitely was under the
impression that i could just give the
worms all my food scraps in the
beginning and i was very wrong
worms eat a lot more than just food
scraps they are actually going to
consume
pretty much everything that's in the bin
that we're adding today
and eventually all of what you see will
be broken down
into worm castings so it's important to
know that
don't over feed your worms we talk about
it in the maintenance section
of my worm book but just a heads up to
you
don't over feed your worms you actually
don't want to add too many food scraps
in the beginning because you can
overwhelm the bin you can invite fight
fruit flies you can invite rodents so
we're going to start very minimally here
in the beginning with just
a few food scraps some of their
favorites mentioned already in the
cooking for your worm section
they really love bananas avocados apple
corers things like that for the better
pears do really well as well i happen to
have some broccoli so i'm adding that
too but again you want to add these
sparingly especially if you're not
starting off with a lot of worms
another thing to keep in mind is that
once your bin is established you should
be able to add more
more food because you'll have more worms
another thing to keep in mind is you
don't want to add too much food and
invite your local pests and rodents
so it's important to not over feed your
bin in the beginning
and cover it up which is the next step i
always like to cover
up the food with compost or soil or
browns
just anything to kind of basically deter
pests and fruit flies and protip if you
are having fruit fly problems with your
bin
it's probably too wet and you probably
need more browns and so i always
recommend
throw some browns on there stop feeding
stop watering your bins
add some little fruit fly traps around
your bin
and you should see a dramatic decrease
in the issue with fruit flies
speaking of moisture as you've seen me
do throughout this process it's
important to keep the bin
moist not too moist but in the beginning
when you're getting it established it's
okay to have it
on the wetter side of things and allow
it to kind of air out as the week goes
on i can kind of eyeball it as time goes
on the goal
is to have it about the consistency of a
rung out sponge that is the eventual
goal so
goldilocks right not too wet not too dry
somewhere
right in between and on the note of
moisture and water like i was saying
you want to make sure that you're using
water that's been filtered we have an rv
filter on our drip lines and hoses now
to
basically eradicate the issue of
chlorine and pesticides and chemicals
that are in city water
and that is it i hope you guys enjoyed
today's video all about how to set up a
worm bin and if you did
a really easy way to support us for free
and show us the love is leave us a
comment
hit that like button subscribe if you
haven't already and do hit the bell as
well so i actually show up in your feed
when i post a video which right now is
about three times a week until our
little one arrives thank you so much for
joining us today
i am so enjoying getting to know you
guys it's been really fun
seeing so many new faces here thank you
so much for all the love and support
and i'll catch you in the next one bye
you